A magician performing at a birthday party
stands inside a circle of 15 kids.
He's going to choose a volunteer
and he wants each kid to have
the same chance of getting
chosen, fair enough.
Now we have three methods
by which he can do it.
Let's just think about whether
each of these methods are fair,
where each kid does have
the same chance of getting chosen.
If they don't lead to each kid
having the same chance of getting chosen,
think about why that is the case.
So, method one, the magician starts
with the birthday boy and moves clockwise,
passing out 100 pieces of
paper numbered one through 100.
He cycles around the circle
until all the pieces are distributed.
He then uses a random number generator
to pick an integer, one through 100,
and chooses the volunteer
with that number.
So just think about what's happening.
So there are 15 kids in a circle.
So there's one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15.
I planned that out amazingly well,
I didn't think I would be
able to fit exactly 15,
but it worked out.
So 15 kids in a circle,
and then he's going
to hand out pieces of paper.
So he's going to give
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
nine, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15.
This person is going to get
pieces of paper one and 16.
Now this person is
going to get two and 17.
You're going to keep going
round and round and round
until all 100 pieces of paper
are going to get distributed.
Now, something to think about
is whether every child here
is going to get the same
number of pieces of paper.
I encourage you to pause this
video and think about that.
If we just keep cycling
around all the way to 100,
does each child get the same
number of pieces of paper?
Well just think about it.
In order to get the same
number of pieces of paper,
100 has to be divisible by 15,
and we know 100 isn't divisible by 15.
15 goes into 100 six times.
Six times 15 is 90, and
you have a remainder of 10.
So what's going to happen is all 15 kids
are going to get six pieces of paper,
and then another 10 of the 15 are going
to get a seventh piece of paper.
So they're not all getting an equal number
of pieces of paper.
So even though he's
randomly picking an interger
between one and 100 some
of the students are going
to have a higher chance
than the other ones.
The 10 that have seven
pieces of paper are going
to have a higher chance
than the other five
who only have six pieces of paper.
So I would say method one is not fair.
Let me write this down.
Not fair.
Sometimes life isn't fair,
but in this case it's not
fair where we define fair
as the same chance of getting chosen.
That's because they all
have different numbers
of pieces of paper.
All of the students are not
equally likely to get picked.
Let's look at method two.
The magician starts with the birthday boy
and moves counterclockwise
passing out 75 pieces
of paper numbered one through 75.
He cycles around the circle until
all the pieces are distributed.
He then uses a random number generator
to pick an integer between one through 75
and chooses the volunteer
with that number.
So I encourage you to pause this video
and think about whether
this one, method two,
whether that one is fair.
Well method two is the same as method one
except for instead of
using 100 pieces of paper,
we're using 75 pieces of paper.
So think about, is 75 divisible by 15?
And 75 is, five times 15 is 75.
So in this situation,
each student is going
to get five pieces of paper.
Each gets five pieces of paper.
So they all have an equally
likely chance of getting picked,
and he's using a random
number generator to pick them.
So they all have an equally likely chance.
I would say method two is, indeed, fair.
They all have the same
chance of getting chosen.
Now think about method three.
The magician starts with the birthday boy
and moves clockwise, passing out 30
pieces of paper numbered one through 30.
So they're all going
to get the same number
of pieces of paper.
They're all going to get
two pieces of paper each.
15 children getting two pieces
of paper each would be 30 pieces of paper.
So that looks reasonable so far.
He cycles around the circle
until all the pieces are distributed.
Everyone gets two pieces.
He gives number one to the birthday boy,
number two to the next kid and so on,
so that all seems reasonable.
Kind of consistent with method two
except instead of 75 it's 30,
and obviously 75 was overkill.
Even here this is overkill,
he just really needs 15 pieces of paper.
He then counts the number
of windows in the room
and chooses the volunteer
with that number.
So the question here is,
is the number of windows in the room,
is it random and is it evenly distributed?
So maybe, maybe you can make a case
depending on what building it's in,
and someone's house, it's somewhat random
on how many windows that
house happens to have,
the house that's happening
to host the birthday party,
but it's not going to
be evenly distributed.
I don't know, there's probably some,
if you were to sit and
plot all of the houses
that had a birthday party,
you'd probably see that it's more likely
that they'd have 10
windows than one window,
and definitely more likely that they have
10 windows than, let's say, 30 windows,
or even maybe 15 windows even.
So it's not going to
be evenly distributed.
Every house has a somewhat
different number of windows,
and the house that's
happening to host the party
seems to be somewhat random,
but it's not going to be
evenly distributed here.
I would say it's not a
kind of a really good
random number generator because
it's not evenly generated.
So I would say method three is not fair.
The number of windows is not
a really good random number generator.
A good random number
generator, we would want,
say, number one through
75 where any of these
have an equally likely
chance of getting picked.
It's somewhat random,
the number of windows that building has,
but they're not all equally likely.